wissen sie was über den sie sind experte
sie lesen alles frisst even die nach
wissen sie etwas über den russischen und
chinesischen impfstoff glauben sie der
würde zugelassen werden von der ema oder
von dem paul-ehrlich-institut ich glaube
dass die zulassung zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt unmöglich ist weil es keinen
publizierten daten gibt die hatte die
bewertung der wirksamkeit ermöglicht
aber auf der anderen seite ist es
wiederum so das war durchaus so konnte
gibt zu glauben dass es der russische
impfstoff vom prinzip her wahrscheinlich
aus einer einigermaßen gute wirkung
bringt der chinesische neben stoffe sind
von der art und weise wie sie aufgebaut
sind relativ primitiv stoffe somit auch
so würde man dort wirksamkeit erwarten
oder weizen die worden bin ich nicht in
den himmel
somit also ich glaube dass die
impfstoffe wirken das aber da der zahn
auf der grundlage von zu wenig da der
bewertung nicht wirklich möglich ist
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren